[Musique]
des rubans verts couleur symbole de
l'islam ont envahi la clôture de l'école
anglophone de chelsea au québec en
soutien à fatema ans varie en seignante
retiré de sa classe pour port du hijab
une centaine de parents à manifester
contre la loi québécoise sur la laïcité
aux côtés de leurs enfants
les enfants n'étaient pas contents ils
ont trouvé la situation injuste l'école
et c'est de leur apprendre la diversité
et l'intégration donc ils n'ont pas
compris pourquoi cet événement n'était
pas dans la lignée de ce qu'on leur
enseigne à la maison et à l'école la loi
interdit le port de signes religieux au
sein des écoles publiques les parents se
questionne toutes ces personnes qui
n'ont pas été embauchés c'est cela qui
me tracasse qui sont ces jeunes qui ont
dû changer de carrière ou qui n'ont pas
eu de poste et sont nombreux je pense
surtout dans notre province nous avons
tellement besoin de professeurs nous
avons tellement besoin d'enseignants
qualifiés instruit équilibré qui devant
les renvoyer à cause de cette loi
m'attriste beaucoup
fatema ans varie a été affecté à un
poste administratif au sein de l'école
cette affaire a relancé le débat sur la
laïcité au québec 4 on adopte une loi il
faut la faire respecter donc là comme
sans scolaire n'avait pas dû embaucher
cette personne là
moi je vis bien avec le choix qu'on a
fait comme la france le fait comme
d'autres pays l'ont fait le choix de la
leis d'elodie une séparation quand les
personnes sont en autorités peuvent pas
porter de signes religieux ses choix
qu'on a faits au québec de façon très
démocratique
mais cette loi provinciale dite loi 21
divise le canada justin trudeau premier
ministre du pays rappelle sa position
sans pour autant intervenir je suis en
profond désaccord avec la loi 21 je
trouve pas que dans une société libre
quelqu'un devrait perdre sa job à cause
de sa religion
c'est ça notre position en tant que
gouvernement c'est ça notre position en
train en termes de partie nous allons
continuer d'être du côté des québécois
qui eux mêmes sont choqués et déçus que
fatima anne-marie et perdu son emploi à
cause de sa religion un maire de
l'ontario a décidé de monter au créneau
face à la loi 21 près de 30 villes du
canada anglophone ont suivi le pas une
contestation d'ampleur nationale
la liberté de religion est inscrite dans
la charte canadienne des droits et des
libertés
des quelle que soit la fois des gens
tout le monde doit avoir les mêmes
opportunités
son combat récolté près de deux millions
de dollars au profit de plusieurs
associations comme le conseil national
des musulmans canadiens ou encore la
world sikh organization of canada une
enveloppe nécessaires pour contester la
loi auprès des tribunaux je crois qu'un
jour on regardera en arrière sur ce
chapitre de l'histoire canadienne et il
y aura de la tristesse et des excuses
qui seront faites aux personnes à qui on
a interdit d'exercer la profession de
leur choix en raison de leur religion
ma critique envers la loi 21 n'est pas
une critique du québec je fais la
critique d'une mauvaise loi d'après un
sondage léger pour l'association
d'études canadiennes
le soutien à cette loi a diminué entre
septembre 2021 et janvier 2022 désormais
55 % des québécois se disent favorables
à la loi 21 contre 60 4% auparavant il
faudrait penser aux autres et pas
seulement aux québécois pure laine
eh bien on a toute la communauté
immigrante également qui est s'installer
au québec personnellement je crois que
c'est bon pour une inclusion de toutes
les minorités on ne veut pas que la
religion n'a pas sur
le social sont fêtés à savoir c'est une
bonne loi ça reste à voir effectivement
c'est dans l'application je dirais j'ai
surtout la tolérance deux visions de la
société canadienne s'opposent face à la
loi 21 celle des libertés individuelles
face à celle des droits collectifs ce
qui rassemble les citoyens dans une
démocratie dans une société civile ce
sont les droits et devoirs civile
prioritairement et secondairement les
les droits religieux
c'est le fondement de pour moi de
l'argumentation de la laïcité au québec
un clivage renforcée par la langue 59%
des sondés francophones sont en faveur
de la loi contre seulement 26 % des
anglophones en sus de sa différence
linguistique il ya différence religieuse
qui est risque d'avoir des conséquences
politiques importantes ce débat c'est à
la fois culturel à la fois juridique et
à la fois constitutionnel est à la fois
philosophique ce sont quatre cordes
sensibles qui sont touchés en même temps
après un passage devant la cour d'appel
du québec au printemps prochain l'avenir
de la loi 21 se jouera devant la cour
suprême du canada